we talked about generation program
generation of language
um even um self-supervised learning in
the visual space for robotics and then
reinforcement learning what do you in
like this whole beautiful spectrum of ai
do you think is a good
benchmark a good test
to strive for
to achieve intelligence that's a strong
test of intelligence you know it started
with alan turing and the touring test
maybe you think natural language
conversation is a good test
so you know it would be nice if for
instance machine would be able to solve
riemann hypothesis in math
that would be i think that would be very
impressive so theorem proving
is that to you proving theorems is a
good oh oh like one thing that the
machine did you would say damn
exactly
okay that would be quite uh quite
impressive i mean the the tricky part
about the benchmarks is
um you know as we are getting closer
with them we have to invent new
benchmarks there is actually no ultimate
benchmark out there yeah see my thought
with the riemann hypothesis would be
the moment the machine proves it would
say okay well then the problem was easy
that's what happens and i mean in some
sense
um that's actually what happens over the
years in ai that like
we get used to things very quickly
you know something i talked to rodney
brooks i don't know if you know that is
he called alpha zero homework problem
because he was saying like there's
nothing special about it it's not a big
leap and i i didn't
well he's coming from one of the aspects
that we referred to as he was part of uh
the founding of irobot which deployed
now tens of millions of robot in the
home so
if you see robots
that are actually in the homes of people
as the legitimate uh instantiation of
artificial intelligence then yes maybe
an ai that plays a silly game like going
chess is not a real accomplishment but
to me it's it's a fundamental leap but i
think we as humans then say okay well
then
that uh that game of chess or go wasn't
that difficult compared to the thing
that's currently unsolved so my
intuition is that
from perspective of the evolution of
you know these ai systems we'll at first
see the tremendous progress in digital
space and the you know the main thing
about digital space is also that you can
everything is that there is a lot of
recorded data plus you can very rapidly
deploy things to billions of people
while in case of uh physical space the
deployment part takes multiple years you
have to manufacture things and
you know delivering it to actual people
it's very hard
so
i'm expecting that the first and the
prices in digital space
of goods they would go you know down to
to let's say marginal costs are to zero
you